merci beaucoup d'être notre invité ce
matin vous êtes secrétaire national
d'Europe Écologie Les Verts on est
ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
régionale représentée par Christelle
Bertrand du groupe La Dépêche bonjour
Christelle
aujourd'hui on conseille des ministres
présentés le décret dissolution du
collectif écologiste les soulèvements de
la terre des solutions engagées après
les événements de sainte solide et après
les violences survenues ce week-end lors
de la manifestation contre Lyon Turing
Gérald Darmanin qui dit qu'aucune cause
ne justifie qu'on laisse des policiers
et des gendarmes cette dissolution n'est
pas justifiée pour vous
écoutez on voit bien que tout ça
s'inscrit dans un cadre beaucoup plus
large et moi je dois vous dire que quand
je suis devenue secrétaire national
d'Europe Écologie Les Verts en décembre
dernier je pensais pas vivre tout ça je
pensais pas notamment être ce matin en
train de discuter avec les proches d'un
militant Europe Écologie Les Verts qui
est en garde à vue
suite à une perquisition hier à 6h du
matin chez lui par les services de
l'anti-terrorisme ce militant il
s'appelle Félix blanc je le connais pas
personnellement enfin comme tous les
militants de ce parti mais quand on me
dit que on a un militant élevé en garde
à vue je me dis bon bah on va suivre ça
ce qui va bien qu'est-ce qui lui
reprocher etc j'appelle sa femme
j'appelle son avocat qui est aussi un
élu marseillais écologiste et puis en
dénouance fil ça me paraît complètement
absurde ce militant Félix blanc il est
agrégé de philosophie quand bien même il
le serait pas ça change pas le problème
mais pour vous dresser le profil il est
fonctionnaire territorial à la mairie de
Marseille au service de la transition
énergétique et tout le monde me dit
c'est absurde en fait on comprend pas sa
femme dit je comprends pas non plus
alors peut-être qu'on peut dire il a une
vie secrète en dehors de il est le jour
militant un gagé de philosophie et la
nuit il casse des trucs bon on attend et
puis on comprend ce qui lui reproché
c'est d'avoir participé à cette action
la cimenterie Lafarge inquiétait pas il
n'y était pas sa femme ne comprend pas
on lui dit Messi c'était le 10 décembre
il y était on a reconnu sur une photo
alors elle elle a changé de téléphone
depuis elle va chercher dans son
téléphone ce qui a pu se passer elle
recherche ses anciens messages le 10
décembre ils étaient dans un repas vous
savez entre amis comme on fait des fois
en décembre pour fêter Noël avant Noël
avec 20 personnes toute la journée donc
il n'est pas à cette action il y a 20
témoins du fait que toute la journée il
fait Noël en famille etc et
en fait ce qu'on comprend c'est qu'il y
a donc apparemment une photo que
personne n'a jamais toujours pas vu ni
lui ni son avocat où il y a quelqu'un
qui lui ressemblerait avec une casquette
rouge et donc la perquisition et là
aussi pour chercher s'il y a une
casquette rouge ils ont retourné toute
sa maison pour voir s'il y avait une
casquette rouge dans sa maison et voilà
on en est là en fait dans un truc
complètement absurde d'une action où il
était pas alors il savait qu'il était
surveillé entre guillemets parce que
quelques mois avant en octobre il avait
participé à une action impertie dans de
Vaucluse autour de c'est une extension
plus de 80 hectares de zones
industrielles en plus sur des terres
agricoles bon tout écolo elle déjà
participé à cette action même pas que
les écolos c'est absurde sur une zone
inondable d'ailleurs le préfet vient de
dire ce projet ne se ferait pas parce
que ça n'allait pas et donc parce qu'il
a été dire que il fallait pas mettre une
zone industrielle sur des champs il est
suspecté d'être à la fin parce qu'il y a
un mec qui lui ressemble avec une
casquette rouge et donc à 6h du matin il
est perquisitionné par l'anti-terrorisme
qui
devant son fils de 5 ans et devant sa
femme alors que il y aurait demandé vous
pouvez venir au commissariat il a une
question il serait venu par ailleurs
qu'est-ce que c'est que cette histoire
on va dénoncer aujourd'hui des méthodes
un peu expéditives une tentative
d'intimidation auprès des militants
écologistes écoutez moi je ne sais pas
je ne connais pas les 15 personnes qui
sont en garde à vue je ne connais pas
l'ampleur de ce qui leur est reproché je
sais que Sandrine Rousseau et Thomas
dessus sont liés hier allez à
Levallois-Perret rendre visite à
certains d'entre qui sont quatrième
sous-sol de la DGSI depuis 24 heures
pour être interrogé je j'ai pas les
éléments j'en sais rien je ne sais pas
tout sûrement ce que je sais c'est que
ce Phénix blanc c'est le seul que je
connais particulièrement il lui
reprochait d'être un endroit où il était
pas et il est suspecté d'y être parce
qu'il avait fait une action sur un champ
avant ou rien n'a été cassé de rien et
qui peut-être il avait une casquette
rouge sur la fac en fait on est où
évidemment que ces sujets des
dissolution n'est soulèvements de la
Terre va occuper beaucoup de place dans
le dans le dans le arrestations
j'ai quand même l'impression qu'il y a
des moyens
qui sont mis en place de répression de
surveillance et disons le mot
d'intimidation parce que
aujourd'hui que vous avez l'impression
de faire tout bien d'être dans nos
violences et des choses là nous violence
sur la prône depuis 40 ans dans ce parti
et on va pas changer de jurisprudence là
dessus c'est notre ADN mais aujourd'hui
quand vous êtes militant FNE quand vous
êtes militant Europe Écologie et vert
quand vous êtes un paysan de la
Confédération paysanne aujourd'hui vous
vous exposez à ce genre de répression
pourquoi pour défendre la planète enfin
on est un moment de l'histoire où les
enfants qui naissent en 2023 c'est pas
la garantir que la planète sera encore
habitable pour pour quand ils auront 30
ans et donc nous on le dit le plus
calmement du monde certains ont décidé
de faire des actions coup de poing mais
je vais vous dire les actions coup de
poing ça fait partie de la communication
politique depuis des années pas des vers
spécifiquement regardez les actions de
la FNSEA ils écrasent des ragondins
devant les préfectures il dépose du
lisier dans devant des prêts chez des
ministres chez des agriculteurs il y a
des actions
je pense pas que Félix blanc est attaqué
force de l'ordre et moi j'ai toujours
condamné la violence la violence contre
les forces policières mais si on veut
poser toute la question du maintien de
l'ordre et du relation entre les forces
policières et pas eux-mêmes d'ailleurs
mais les cons sont donnés et limitant
écolo composent le problème complètement
moi je peux vous dire que au lion Turin
ce week-end
pour avoir été très en lien avec les
copains qui étaient sur place dont
Cyrielle châtelain qui est présidente du
groupe écologiste donc Gwendoline
delbordfield qui est député européenne
de l'Isère qui suit aussi depuis des
années il y a eu énormément de
tempérance dans tout vous dire qu'il y a
une tentative de criminaliser un
mouvement qui n'est pas forcément mais
ça me paraît évident dans son entièreté
ça me paraît évident et d'ailleurs je
vous dis il y a aussi une responsabilité
médiatique je pas vous en particulier
mais voyez par exemple quand on a fait
les seins de Soline
en mars il y a eu la Confédération de
paysanne a fait une grande action pour
construire une serre chez un paysan et
pour montrer enfin pour montrer ce qu'il
en est l'entrée de paysanne etc ces
actions personne n'en parle jamais les
gens nous disent mais c'est complètement
cucul vous êtes naïf vous servez à rien
les bisounours etc en fait on part c'est
comme toujours culte c'est ça la
violence occulte et puis surtout on voit
aussi les tentatives de déstabilisation
quand on met 32 la force de l'ordre à
Sainte Soline pour défendre un trou il
n'y avait rien à casser il y avait un
trou là on en parle et évidemment
annoncé oui mais quand vous annoncez
3200 forces de l'ordre et que vous
répétez tous les jours en disant il y
aura des drones il y aura des
hélicoptères évidemment ceux qui sont
intéressés par ça vienne moi j'ai fait
le quelques semaines après la
manifestation aussi des soulèvements de
la terre ou à roues près de Rouen sur le
contournement de Rouen j'ai croisé zéro
force de l'ordre et il y a eu aucun
incident je dis pas que il y a une
corrélation exacte entre les deux
évidemment qu'il y a des des moments qui
peuvent plus tendus que d'autres mais
vous voyez il y a eu la date pour
enfants on a construit avec des
menuisiers des toboggans pour les
enfants avec des palettes en bois dans
la forêt on a observé les muscade en
dorés on a croisé on a creusé une marre
pour les tritons crêtés et elle a
garderie parce qu'il y avait toujours un
lieu pour les enfants ils ont fabriqué
des jumelles avec des rouleaux de papier
toilette ça personne n'en a parlé mais à
un moment on se dit aussi que Marina il
y a tout un engrenage aussi de violence
et que on veut assimiler toutes
l'écologie à la violence pour mieux
occulter aussi le fond des problèmes et
moi je ne le laisserai pas ce
gouvernement faire des écologistes les
boucs émissaires de leur inaction
climatique et de tout ce qui n'arrive
pas
par exemple sur la les tensions qu'on
veut nous démontrer entre agriculteurs
et écologiste moi je suis désolé j'ai
d'excellents rapports avec les
agriculteurs et d'ailleurs le président
de la FNSEA peut-être vous choquer mais
s'il veut qu'on se rencontre on se
rencontre et on parle comme je l'ai fait
que prédécesseurs au salon de
l'agriculture vous l'avez rencontrer
depuis son patron
et donc on veut nous dire c'est très
tendu de cette culture mais c'est pas
vrai il y a assez tendu entre les Verts
et l'extrême droite et donc quand
certains agriculteurs ont des méthodes
d'extrême droite évidemment il se
tournent vers nous en disant angry
bâchis citez-moi une phrase dans toute
ma vie que j'ai dit DAGRI bashing je
vous mets au défi par contre les
colobashing oui ça existe dans ce pays
il y a eu des cellules Déméter mises en
place pour défendre les agriculteurs les
protéger contre l'agribashing des
cellules Demeter qui aujourd'hui en
quête sur des militants écolos dont par
exemple Thor et d'avoir des enfants
victimes de cancers pédiatriques et
d'essayer de se constituer en collectif
pour dire les pesticides sont épendues
où comment parce qu'ils essayent de
comprendre eux-mêmes ce qui s'est passé
parce que là il reste leur répond pas
ils sont dans une dans un trou noir
juridique sanitaire et ne comprennent
pas et donc aujourd'hui si vous dites
bah il y a un problème de pesticides
mais il y a un cluster de cancer
pédiatrique on aimerait comprendre vous
êtes suivi par la cellule des methers et
qu'est-ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui pour
protéger les militants écolos pas grand
chose donc nous on est aussi en train de
s'organiser et je le dis et là aussi
très calmement mais on est en train
d'organiser un observatoire des
violences faites aux écolos qui soient
associatifs politiques non avec
parce que on se rend compte
qu'aujourd'hui ben va falloir qu'on se
défende par nous-mêmes parce que tout ce
discours de Gérald darmann comment vous
organisez ce monsieur est ministre de
l'intérieur quand le ministre de
l'Intérieur dit éco terrorisme et que
sabotage en faisant amalgame total la
conséquence sur le terrain c'est qu'il y
a une recrudescence des agressions
contre les militants écologistes de gens
qui disent bah c'est le ministère de
l'Intérieur qui l'a dit c'est des
terroristes donc allons-y on va se
rendre justice nous-mêmes comme le
ferait tout le monde français et donc ça
ça met en danger des militants sur le
terrain donc moi il y a vraiment le
climat pour moi qui est délétère qui
m'inquiétait énormément et je vais vous
dire on laissera pas faire ça alors vous
disiez tout à l'heure les actions
violentes au culte tout ce qu'on fait
dans comme action non violente est-ce
que justement pour éviter ces actions
violentes il est pas juste de déclarer
comme ça va être fait en conseil des
ministres aujourd'hui la dissolution des
soulèvements de la terre mais moi
j'attends de voir quels éléments ils ont
pour justifier cette dissolution parce
que s'ils veulent dissoudre tout groupe
qui mène des actions coup de poing ça va
faire beaucoup de monde quand même cette
dissolution j'attends d'avoir les
éléments soi-disant que c'est tout le
dossier était complet en avril ça n'a
pas été dissou en avril donc personne
permettait pas de penser que c'était
peut-être pas aussi complexe j'attends
de savoir ce qui justifie cette atteinte
à la liberté d'associations de réunions
de on va voir mais les soulèvements de
la terre c'est quoi aujourd'hui c'est la
Ligue des droits de l'Homme la
Confédération paysage Europe Écologie
Les Verts des fermes des collectifs
sinon merci c'est des gens c'est Valérie
Masson Delmotte qui est experte du GIEC
et Paléo qui est climatologue qui est
directrice de recherche au commissariat
pour l'énergie atomique c'est Cyril Dion
qui dont on connaît tous les
documentaires sur le vivant ils vont
quoi ils vont ils vont ils vont faire
comment ils vont dissoudre toutes ces
tous ces gens ils vont nous interdire de
travailler ensemble
pour comparer les soulèvements de la
terre avec votre partie avec Europe
Écologie Les Verts c'est pas que je
compare c'est que pour vous c'est la
même chose non pour moi c'est pas la
même chose je vous dis juste que il y a
eu un moment on me demandait toujours
est-ce que vous êtes des soulèvements de
la terre ou pas moi j'en sais rien je
fais plusieurs actions qui sont
d'ailleurs souvent très bien passées je
sais pas qui
quand ils ont menacé de dissoudre ils
ont dit nous sommes tous des
soulevénements de la terre il se trouve
qu'il y a plus de 100000 personnes qui
ont signé ces pétitions ils vont faire
quoi ils vont dissoudre tous les gens
qui ont ils vont nous interdit de parler
entre nous quand on va se retrouver au
Larzac en août parce qu'il y a un grand
rassemblement prévu on n'aura pas droit
de se parler quand j'invite bah si non
merci aux journées d'été des écologistes
au Havre en août je n'ai pas le droit de
le mettre sur le programme parce que
c'est une association c'est une
reconstitution de ligue des soute je ne
comprends pas comment ils vont faire
opérationnellement je peux vous dire en
tout cas que juridiquement suivra ça
avec beaucoup d'attention alors par
exemple parce que il y a les coups de
boutoir qu'on a liberté associative
aussi dans ce pays ça commence à bien
faire par exemple
à des actions sur la fête de la musique
par exemple vous soutenez ben moi je
serai avec eux à 17h devant le Conseil
d'État pour une conférence de presse et
les militants écologistes de ce pays où
ils seront rassemblements seront
rassemblés dans plusieurs villes de
France devant les sous-préfecture et les
préfectures comme ça a été fait
d'ailleurs en mars quand tu es la
première menace et je peux vous dire que
tout est là aussi très bien passé alors
dernière question sur le sujet la
majorité aujourd'hui imagine sanctionner
les députés qui participeraient à des
manifestations illégale et
particulièrement ceux qui s'affiche avec
leur écharpe tricolore est-ce que vous
comprenez
vous voyez le truc c'est que à partir du
moment où on interdit des manifs sans
que les militants comprennent bien
pourquoi c'était le cas de la manif de
Sainte-Souline en octobre dernier moi
j'avais pas prévu d'y aller quand on dit
la manif est interdite on comprend pas
pourquoi ils veulent pas qu'on parle des
bassines du coup j'y vais j'y vais parce
que je suis lu alors je sais pas
parlementaire mais je suis élu et je me
dis quand une manifestation était
interdite ce que vous avez 30000
personnes qui sont annoncées comme
c'était le casinoline en mars évidemment
qu'il faut y être pour surveiller ce qui
se passe ou pas évidemment qu'il faut y
être pour apporter du secours aux
victimes s'il y en a évidemment qu'il
faut y être pour raconter ensuite ce qui
s'est passé ou pas moi je rappelle
qu'après mars à Sainte solide on m'a
beaucoup conspuide d'y avoir été mais il
se trouve que j'avais 200 militants
écolos qui avait prévu de participer des
gens locaux qui suivent ce combat depuis
plus de 30 ans avec les paysans locaux
etc évidemment qu'ils y vont mon rôle du
chef de partie c'est d'être là aussi
avec eux au cas où quelque chose se
passe mal et puis on y va se passe s'il
se passe et puis on entend monsieur
Darmanin dire qu'il y a produits de
grenade sur les élus dire qu'il y a
jamais une grenade sur les blessés dire
que il y avait pas d'armes de guerre
tout ce qu'on avait vu pourtant si je
n'avais pas été là avec les
parlementaires Thomas do Sud David
Corman Marie Toussaint etc pour raconter
Daniel salmon Benoît habite au fait il y
en avait plein si la Ligue des droits de
l'homme n'avait pas été de l'autre côté
parce qu'on était pas avec les mêmes
blessés en urgence vitale pour faire le
même travail de l'autre côté avec la
légitimité de la LDH on n'aurait jamais
su la vérité et moi il y a un truc je
veux toujours la vérité dans la vie les
forces de police et qui il faut des des
vigiles de police enfin c'est pas c'est
pas mon travail mais notamment je vais
être dans le cadre de l'enquête de
l'inspection nationale de la gendarmerie
je vais être entendu comme témoin et
c'est normal en fait et donc moi je ne
vous dis pas que tout s'est très bien
passé et des deux côtés c'était
manifeste qui a eu des problèmes mais il
y a un truc qui m'importe dans la vie
c'est la vérité et désolé mais je ne
suis plus en confiance avec certains
membres de ce gouvernement qui pourtant
sont ministre de l'Intérieur et c'est
grave en fait quand vous êtes ministre
quand vous qualifiez vos composants
politiques de terrorisme y compris de
terroristes intellectuels je sais même
pas ce que ça veut dire sur les
retraites que vous leur mettez une cible
dans le dos que vous faites tellement de
demandes dans le dos Gérald Darmanin
mais quand les agriculteurs viennent
m'agresser dans le Lot-et-Garonne ou
dans l'eau dans 10 ans et côtéoristes
etc vous pensez que ça vient d'où vient
on va suivre tout ça de tout près de
très près pardon la dissolution des
soulèvements de la terre comment vous
comptez vous y opposer comment vous
pouvez vous y opposer mais par tous les
moyens mais c'est quoi tous les moyens
par tous les moyens légaux vous verrez
on a beaucoup de ressources vous savez
les écologistes on imagine évidemment
mais les écoles il y a un truc qu'on
pourra jamais nous enlever nos valeurs
notre détermination et le sourire qu'on
ne quittera jamais parce que il y a un
moment où tout ce qu'on fait est trop
dur mais vous allez voir qu'avec
beaucoup de détermination beaucoup
d'humour beaucoup de non-violence on va
continuer à défendre nos idées n'en
déplaises américaines
vous allez aussi continuer à défendre
vos idées sur le lion Turin est-ce que
par exemple à la constitution d'une ZAD
sur le sur le site
ça mais sur le lion Turin l'exemple il
est intéressant il y a Elisabeth borne
elle annonce 100 milliards d'euros pour
le train d'ici 2030 c'est urgence et
vital toutes les petites lignes qui
crèvent les trains qui sont en retard
parce que c'est pas les passages à
niveau autant en panne tout le temps le
manque de conducteur enfin tout ça on
voit donc elle annonce un grand plan 100
milliards d'euros jusque 2030 le lion
Turin le projet c'est 30 milliards
d'euros c'est-à-dire que c'est un tiers
l'équivalent d'un tiers de l'enveloppe
d'ici 2030 ça sera pas mis en service
avant 2042 alors ce qui est à la France
qui est pas là totalité de
grandeur c'est c'est un tiers
et l'autre et partager entre français et
italien je vous donne des ordres de
grandeur c'est 50
millions de 10 millions de tonnes de CO2
rien que pour la construction ce sera
pas mis en service avant 2042 il y a des
gros sujets sur l'eau puisqu'il y a 667
points d'eau qui seront au-dessus du
tunnel et dans une montagne fait dès que
vous creusez ça peut c'est imprévisible
de comment ça peut affecter des sources
qui tout d'un coup peuvent se tarir et
c'est il y a quand même des plusieurs
villages qui dépendent généralement
c'est source d'eau et si ça arrive c'est
irréversible on peut pas prévoir si ça
arrive ou pas si ça arrive c'est
irréversible c'est l'équivalent de 2000
terrains de foot de zone agricoles qui
disparaissent c'est des sommes
considérables enfin il y a un moment où
ça n'a pas de sens ces projets en 2023
n'ont plus de ce projet c'est cette vise
à développer le fret pour désengorger
les camions des vallées des Alpes est-ce
que vous les écologistes vous pouvez
vous opposer à ça et vous savez qu'il y
a déjà un trajet possible pour aller de
France en Italie avec du fret une ligne
qui est complètement sous-exploitée il
suffirait de la remettre qui date oui
mais elle existe et elle marche et avec
très peu d'investissement en tout cas
beaucoup moins de ces 30 milliards
d'euros vous pouvez la remettre en
fonction et c'est tout de suite c'est
pas en 2042 parce que l'urgence
climatique le GIEC me dit on a plus que
deux à trois ans pour inverser la
tendance et là on nous parle d'un projet
qui va être en 2042 c'est une
plaisanterie j'espère donc il y a un
moment où vous voyez des militants qui
depuis des dizaines d'années se battent
contre ces projets inutiles le
contournement Est de Rouen dont je vous
parlais c'est ça fait 50 ans que le
projet existe imaginez-vous bien que si
depuis 60 ans il se fait pas c'est
peut-être qu'il y a une raison y compris
le maire de Val-de-Reuil qui est numéro
3 de LVMH il s'oppose maintenant au
projet avec nous donc il y a une
bataille culturelle qui progresse et et
en fait le pouvoir politique a toujours
un temps de retard sur ses évidences que
pour le coup paysan habitant citoyen et
locaux comprennent en général avant eux
donc alors allons-y vous renvoie que
vous vous opposez à des projets de
développement c'est le cas pour c'est ce
qu'ils disent sur le lion Turin sur
l'autoroute à 69 en Occitanie est-ce que
vous avez qu'est-ce que vous leur
répondez vous répondez à ça il y a en
France un million
kilomètres de route un million 100 mille
kilomètres de route c'est le record
d'Europe non mais c'est le record
d'Europe de kilomètres de route et dans
l'absolu et par habitant c'est à dire
quand vous êtes un Français moyen vous
avez 120 m² de route par français dans
ce pays c'est-à-dire plus que ce que
vous avez surface dans votre logement en
réalité et donc des routes on en manque
pas en France je veux dire et des
projets qui sont bloqués depuis des
dizaines d'années qu'on ne sait pas
financer où il y a toujours parce qu'on
est des gens sérieux chez les écolos
contrairement à ce que je voudrais vous
faire penser on a toujours le projet
alternatif moins cher plus respectueux
des terres agricoles plus respectueux de
l'eau plus respectueux des des citoyens
qui existent et qui est moins cher qui
est possible plus rapidement parce que
c'est moins gigantesque et donc on est
en 2023 maintenant les projets
inutiles du passé bah faut juste arrêter
en fait ça ne convaincue personne et de
toute manière même quand on est pas là
ils se font pas parce qu'en fait ils
arrivent pas à les financer ils arrivent
plus à les faire ça contredit toute leur
loi sur l'eau sur les sur 0
artificialisation net donc stop en fait
tout ce qu'on est en train de se
raconter est-ce que ça veut dire qu'on
se dirige vers violent entre partisans
de la croissance classique et vous qui
souhaitez stopper certains projets et
plutôt partisans de la décroissance on
voit bien que les gens ont du mal à se
parler vous êtes descendu en Occitanie
vous lisez tout à l'heure vous avez été
avec Sandrine Rousseau agressé par des
agriculteurs ça s'est malignant
d'extrême droite et ça c'est mal passé
avec la personne qui a été à l'origine
du lac de cossade on voit qu'il y a des
choses qui le dépanne se fait pas
simplement est-ce qu'on est dans de
France qui n'arrivent plus à se parler
alors la première chose que j'ai envie
de vous dire c'est que moi je serai
toujours pour le dialogue la désescalade
de la violence le dialogue et tous les
ministres qui sur leur sujet sont
concernés par ces dossiers et qui ont
envie de me rencontrer je les
rencontrerai si le président de la FNSE
va rencontrer je le rencontrerai et y
compris la coordinationale s'ils veulent
qu'on se rend compte qu'on se rend
compte j'ai toujours dialogué avec tout
le monde c'est très bien en début
d'émission que vous les militants écolos
se font agresser et certains membres
écologistes sont aussi violents mais
c'est pour ça que quand je voulais pas
rencontrer les habits de borne sur les
le prochain mois parce qu'il y avait un
blocage sur les retraites je l'ai quand
même rencontré juste pour lui parler de
ces sujets là et on a beaucoup discuté
et je pense qu'elle comprend un certain
nombre de choses enfin je pense qu'on se
comprend sur ces sujets de liberté
publique aussi et de et de risques
climatiques il y a d'autres membres du
gouvernement et qui on se comprend moins
mais peut-être que si on se parlait ça
irait mieux donc pas de problème
j'utilise pas que ça résolve tout le
problème mais je pense que des fois faut
aussi savoir les choses genre en fait
moi je suis mal à l'aise pour
interpeller toujours par plateau télé
interposé des gens peut-être qu'à un
moment il faut qu'on se voit et qu'on se
parle mais sûr là maintenant par exemple
mais tous ils sont tous concernés par
l'écologie l'écologie elle est partout
et en attendant surtout nulle part sur
les affrontements dont vous parlez c'est
intéressant parce qu'en fait Serge
Bousquet Cassagne donc le président de
la Chambre d'agriculture qui est en fait
aussi chef qui est de la coordination
orale qui est un syndicat d'extrême
droite agriculteur
la justice elle est forte avec les
faibles et faibles avec les formes dans
ce pays parce que Serge Bousquet
Cassagne il a compris il a oui mais il
continue moi il se vantent à tout le
monde d'être condamné plein de fois qui
s'en fout qui fait quand même son là qui
qui me lasse de mort quand même des
militants écolos qui leur dit toi tu
finiras au fond de mon lac de Caussade
et il y a aucune poursuite qui est
donnée à ces gens ça c'était un militant
effet nœud à d'autres militants Europe
Écologie vert qui toute l'année se tape
ce genre de personnage à tel point que
moi quand je j'annonce qu'on déplacement
de Lot-et-Garonne la préfecture me
demande de pas venir en disant vous ne
le connaissez pas il est dangereux et
donc j'ai dit mais attendez et les élus
sont une protection et les élus locaux
me disent attention il est il passe à là
il va faire bénéficier une protection
de camionnette Darmanin de Monsieur
Darmanin et je les en remercie parce
qu'en fait je vais pas arrêter de me
déplacer un territoire parce que il y a
une omerta de l'extrême droite dans des
territoires et d'ailleurs j'ai été
remerciée par beaucoup d'élus locaux qui
m'avait demandé de pas venir en disant
mais il est dangereux il y aura des
fusils des chasseurs je m'attendais ils
vont faire quoi une fusillade en pleine
rue non mais tire en l'air donc il y a
un moment ou dans ce pays oui il y a un
problème de comme de de poids de mesure
je vous donne un autre exemple Alizée
qui s'enchaîne au terrain de
Roland-Garros de dernière rénovation en
écrivant il reste 1800 jours sur son
t-shirt elle fait de mal à personne 40
heures de garde à vue extrêmement brutal
mais les gens qui nous mènent par contre
dans le mur eux ça va vous voyez on
parle de Lafarge moi je suis pas pour la
violence envers leur site et encore
moins évidemment envers les personnes
mais ils sont ils ont plaidé coupable
pour avoir financer l'État islamique
parce qu'il voulait continuer à faire
financer leur terrorisme leur
cimenterie là-bas ils ont donné du cash
à l'état islamique
blanc qui a arrêté par les services de
l'antitoris donc un moment où et moi
j'ai un problème de codeur il nous reste
deux minutes de questions une question
d'abord sur les sénatoriales est-ce
qu'il y aura une liste d'union de la
gauche au sénatorial à Paris ah ben
alors ça je vais vous dire vous saurez
Écologie Les Verts s'associe à la liste
d'union qui encourt entre le PS par j'ai
l'impression que le problème dans la
liste de Paris c'est aujourd'hui un
problème entre socialiste et donc c'est
ça qui doit être réglé en premier donc
pour le moment vous restez indépendant
très sincèrement oui vous souhaitez le
rester pas forcément toujours mais vous
avez compris que les négociations
sénatoriales n'étaient pas tout à fait
simple et peut-être que c'est normal en
tout cas il y aura une union des
écologistes c'est sénatoriales dans
toute la France et je vais vous dire ça
peut toujours été le cas donc ça c'est
bon et puis moi ça me paraîtrait normal
de travailler avec le Parti communiste
le Parti socialiste au sénatorial c'est
pas simple partout je ne désespère
jamais vous avez remarqué donc je pense
qu'on va y arriver la discussion quel
est votre objectif vous avez 12
sénateurs à l'heure actuelle quel est
l'objectif de votre partie bah c'est
dans l'avoir plus évidemment parce que
on apporte une voix singulière en fait
au Sénat et puis surtout il y a des
endroits où on en a pas par exemple dans
les hauts de France mais on n'a jamais
eu enfin il y avait Marie Blandin qui
était assez connu pour son travail
pendant 10 ans sur plein de sujets
l'amiante les danseurs d'alerte là on a
une candidate qui s'appelle Céline
cavennec ça pourrait être la seule
parlementaire écologiste des Hauts de
France et donc on estime que dans les
territoires comme ça c'est pas normal
d'en avoir zéro donc on veut renforcer
notre présence à Paris en
Loire-Atlantique dans plein d'autres
départements et on veut rentrer au Sénat
pour d'autres départements et j'ai
grande confiance en la qualité de nos
candidats sur les européennes vous êtes
très clair sur le fait que vous ne
voulez pas d'alliance avec la France
insoumise vos positions sont très
éloignées est-ce que vous pourriez
travailler je précise que c'est juste
pour les européennes on travaille sur
plein de les européennes pas de problème
sur les européennes est-ce que vous
pouvez travailler à une liste commune
avec les socialistes et place publique
bah écoute là vos positions de discuter
sur les sénatoriales si vous voulez bien
ça m'a pas l'air tout à fait simple et
puis fermez pas la porte
on a préparé une liste écologiste au
sénateur aux européennes on est en train
de discuter du projet on désignera nos
candidats le 1er juillet puis notre tête
de liste avant l'ami juillet on arrive à
tête de liste ah bah moi on a deux
excellents candidats vous avez compris
Marie Toussaint et David Corban souvent
la secrétaire nationale des Verts dit je
ne prends pas je ne soutiens pas en fait
je prends pas parti à ce débat moi je
vais rompre cette tradition en disant
que je soutiens les deux parce qu'ils
sont vraiment fantastiques non mais très
très bien
c'est un luxe quand vous avez deux
candidats super la tête de liste et que
vous dit mais quel que soit celui qui
est intéressant
publique et je pense que beaucoup de
militants écolos ont du mal à choisir
mais vous fermez pas la porte à une
liste commune avec les socialistes
écologiste ouverte ceux qui veulent
s'ouvrir une liste écologiste pourront
venir discuter il y a pas de problème et
ce c'est qui mon père et les filles ça
on a compris ouverte à faire une liste
le PC bah des écologistes aussi par
exemple je pense pas que Fabien Roussel
et envie de venir faire une liste
écologiste mais avec Olivier Faure
européenne bah il semble
ça marche pas comme ça la politique donc
tout le monde a bien compris que en 2027
il y avait quand même beaucoup de gens
dans ce pays qui voulaient pas se
résigner à choisir entre Édouard
Philippe et Marine Le Pen bon bah je
fais partie de ces gens-là je mettrai
tout en oeuvre pour qu'ils candidature
unique et Jean-Luc Mélenchon ah bah ça
c'est un autre problème la question de
savoir de qui en tout cas nous
écologistes nous ne faisons pas d'une
candidature écologiste un préalable à
l'Union les socialistes j'ai compris
qu'ils disaient la même chose et je
pense qu'une fois que tout le monde aura
dit la même chose on pourra commencer à
travailler sur unique ça veut dire que
la réponse n'est pas évidente
pour moi elle est de devoir faire une
candidature unique et après on a 4 ans
pour travailler à qui à comment à quel
projet et ça doit se faire
collectivement c'est pas par des tweets
de menaces par des houcases par des si
c'est ça je fais un malheur en fait ça
doit se faire Emmanuel
bon pas non mais ça doit se faire dans
la coopération surtout la politique en
partenariat ne peut pas être un rapport
de force pour qu'on comprenne bien vous
allez discuter tout avec Manuel bon par
et qu'on puisse la présence de la fille
sur les listes européennes sur votre
liste européenne arrêtez enfin vous avez
une obsession c'est pas mal ça nous
intéresse je vais on va discuter plein
de choses bon d'accord allez on verra ça
après votre déjeuner merci beaucoup
marine tondeleine d'avoir été notre
invité regarde la Une de La Dépêche du
Midi ce sont les arrêts maladie
Christelle arrêt maladie les médecins
dans le viseur c'est à la Une de votre
journal merci Christelle on passe au
club des territoires